welcome photon warriors
I invented laser tag about 30 years ago
that game we all grew up playing high on
pizza and soda on a weekend night it was
invented here in Dallas Texas by this
guy George Carter laser tag might never
have happened if it hadn't been for one
particular movie the movie star wars I
was sitting at a theater in Las Vegas
and watched them going up and down the
halls of the ship shooting lasers at one
another getting interrupted there George
there are no actual lasers and laser tag
yeah I found out early on that there was
a rule against shooting lasers at people
there was a federal agency it didn't
allow that ah back to the story I
thought it put it in some sort of
context and make rules and we've got a
great game then George is an inventor he
has a lot of patents actually about a
dozen Oh a couple of his other
inventions motorized surfboard the first
modern bumper boat off-road vehicle
called the Snoopy but we here in Dallas
to talk to him about a game he called
Photon my first choice was laser tag and
my trademark attorney said that's too
generic you'll never be able to get a
trade name on that so we had to come up
with another name but it was a little
different than laser tag is today right
we promoted running and actually being
very competitive
George's ideal game was actually
designed for twenty something year old
men not pre tween birthday parties at
family centers conceptually it had three
main tenants first
yeah the arena was very important we had
some facilities at very large arenas up
to 20,000 square feet the second the
field needed to be symmetrical so that
you had an equal advantage or no
advantage to either team and the third
ya mercy of environment lots of special
effects lots of music lots of lights
lots of fog that that really got you
into the game
so what happened well photon toys in
1986 were the number one boys category
but it was actually kind of an error
because it lowered our demographic age
George doesn't play laser tag anymore
call him a purist no I got other things
to do - I've got other hobbies I grew up
playing laser tag at a Family Center and
having learned about photon yeah it
seems cooler but I like laser tag too